alors que les chefs s'apprête à disputer
leur première joute sur le thème de la
santé
raymonde chagnon une résidente de
mirabel les ramène à la réalité et j'ai
peur peur de finir par survivre dans un
ch celle des voici ma question que me
proposez vous il y aurait plus d'argent
dans le siège cld du québec si le
gouvernement libéral n'avait pas donné
autant médecins suite françois legault
il avait donné un milliard de trop aux
médecins si vous déchirez l'entendent
vous mettez en péril tous les soins les
nouveaux services que les médecins
donnent maintenant si les brouillards se
retrouve aussi sur la défensive quand
jean françois lisée lui rappelle que la
protectrice du citoyen a blâmé son
gouvernement pour avoir réduit les
services de santé
vous aviez deux milliards de dollars de
ses surplus n'avait dans vos coffres
n'avez vous avez dit continuer non
j'aimerais sur le partage et la
compassion avec vous j'ai pas de
monopole
mais vous avez démontré que vous avez un
grand déficit de compassion c'est parti
là ne croit plus au système public de
santé oms vous éclairer on le souhaite
totalement quand le chef libéral s'est
fait attaqué sur sa ville en éducation
ou avait coupé dans l'aide aux enfants
que je le connais plus vulnérables ou
écoutez vous pardonnerai jamais sacré
monsieur coué philippe couillard appel à
ses adversaires qu'ils n'ont pas fait
mieux dans le passé mais vous êtes le
seul ministre l'éducation le seul milieu
de l'éducation
que dire en chambre ou citoyens puis aux
jeunes que c'était bon de couper dans
l'éducation vous l'avez dit c'est
pourquoi il faut tenir compte de
l'histoire modifications rien et votre
force et votre responsable est pire qu
sont les votes sur les thèmes de
l'économie
la comparaison avec l'ontario fait
partie du débat manon massé propose que
les québec augmente aussi le salaire
minimum à 15 dollars pour contrer la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans vos
économies dans votre genre d'économie
c'est le bon moment pour améliorer les
conditions de travail des gens aient
augmenté challenge déjà perdront pas les
jazz pour ça que tu arrives et du tout
en ontario depuis le début de la
campagne électorale françois legault
affirme qu'il veut réduire le nombre
d'immigrants
alors que fait les fuyards veut
maintenir l'an
environ 50 milles par année le test des
valeurs n'a aucune raison d'être
donley un résident de brossard qui
perlaient ademe le français lorsqu'il
est arrivé au québec en 1975 évident les
chefs à mieux expliquer leur position en
matière d'immigration
mais on parle pas d'expulser des
citoyens on parle d'expirer des gens qui
sont pas ces familles ces hommes ces
femmes ces enfants qui vous écoute vous
leur fait peur les québécois sont tannés
de vous avoir remis aux donneurs de
leçons québec monsieur couillard
monsieur legault je partage votre
résiliation en compte
françois legault est convaincu qu'il
parviendra à rapatrier des pouvoirs en
immigration
le chef libéral met en doute sa capacité
à se tenir debout devant ottawa
il lui rappelle son absence le jour où
tous les chefs ont fait front commun en
campagne électorale pour défendre la
gestion de l'offre
on était réunie à saint-hyacinthe vous
avez choisi d'une paye a été de faire
une conférence téléphone avait un peu
parlé on peut pratiquer monsieur legault
lorsque c'était nécessaire que vous
soyez là vous n'y étiez pas une fin de
débats animés qui donne le ton pour la
deuxième partie de cette campagne
électorale
ici véronique prince radio canada
montréal